now to the pandemic and the continuing
struggle to come to terms with what
we're all living through right now today
the biden administration will mark one
million lives that have been lost to
covet it is a huge loss that would have
been unthinkable when this pandemic
began even now more than two years later
debate is still raging in washington
over how to respond nancy cortes is at
the white house with more on this story
nancy i remember when the death toll was
100 000 and that made front page news
because we thought that was unthinkable
right and now the president is marking
this new grim milestone a million deaths
here in the u.s and he's going to be
releasing gail a pre-recorded speech
later this morning to mark that solemn
occasion he has also ordered flags at
federal buildings to be lowered to half
staff to mark the 1 million american
deaths from the pandemic meanwhile white
house officials are already warning of
another deadly wave that could infect
100 million people with a new omicron
variant that is already in this country
the president has been pleading with
congress to pass another 10 billion
dollars in coveted funding to make sure
that the u.s can purchase enough coveted
vaccines and tests and anti-viral
treatments to be ready for the fall but
republicans are saying they are not
going to vote for that money unless they
also get a vote on keeping this
trump-era pandemic policy in place it's
called title 42 and it blocks migrants
at the border from seeking asylum due to
covid concerns in this country so that's
an impasse right now president biden as
you know came into office wanting to get
the pandemic completely under control
and at one point he even predicted we
were experiencing independence from the
virus but while the covet 19 death rate
was actually on the decline last summer
we then saw these spikes from highly
contagious delta and omicron variants
which fueled cases across the country
today the president is set to co-host
the second annual covid summit it's
going to be a virtual summit it's meant
to try to convince world leaders to
invest more in covet 19 vaccines and
testing because as we know gail covid
anywhere affects cases and deaths
everywhere
all right nancy we do remember that
thank you so much